[Musique]
depuis plus de 50 ans un roman
emblématique a rassemblé des
générations aujourd'hui il est enfin
adapté à
l'écran Dieu tu es là c'est moi
margar des changements qui surviennent à
la puberté dès lors le sang peut
s'écouler par le
vagin s'il te plaît je te demande de
faire une seule chose pour
moi laisse-moi être normal comme toutes
les autres filles de mon âge s'il te
plaît pitié pitié pitié pitié
pitié j'ai décidé de te laisser
rejoindre mon club secret
copine si vous voulez être membre du
club alors vous devez porter un soutien
gorge
oh tu tu crois que tu en as besoin ça se
passe bien tu peux me dire la vérité
trésor je vais bien très bien oui le
comité d'amélioration à la vie de
l'établissement des volontaires le
Comité d'Action Sociale le comité de
collecte de fond et vous alors j'ai lu
que quand on nétait pas entouré de ses
proches c'était radical l'espérance de
vie se réduisait de façon drastique mais
j'en ai profité je ne peux pas me
plaindre découverte de
soi-même est une
aventure qui dure toute la vie c'est
fatigant toujours essayer d'être à la
hauteur pas
vrai je suis plus sûr de vouloir le
faire c'est histoire d'être prête fa que
ça soit une femme
Seigneur Dieu tu es là c'est moi
margarite tu crois que l'une d'entre
nous lui ressemblera à 19
ans augmente augmente tour de poitrine
[Musique]
Aug